hey guys in this video I'm gonna quickly
warn you against it top three foods with
high estrogen levels that most guys out
there still eat without realizing it now
these are the type of foods that you
need to try and avoid because when your
estrogen levels are too high
it can create a lot of problems like
what well like destroying your hormone
balance and also you can start to
experience a lot of feminine
characteristics and you don't want that
so let's get to the video made mistakes
but mistakes make you strong just very
quick if it's your first time here on my
channel I'm Daniel Moritz and welcome to
D LM model lifestyle
subscribe and also click that
notification bell so you won't miss any
up in next videos now let's start with
the first food that you need to avoid
sugar now this is a no-brainer because
by now you've probably been educated a
lot about the devastating effects that
sugar has on your body right but sugar
also raised estrogen levels and lower
progesterone to stop eating foods with
too much sugar in them stop adding them
in things like coffee and tea and
cereals because you're destroying your
own body soy now let me make this very
clear there's a huge difference between
genetically modified so you know
processed soy and fermented soybeans I
remember when I was in in Japan they
used to eat a lot of soy which is called
natto and that's fine that's different
but stay away from any bad processed soy
like soy milk or even soy protein powder
that's genetically modified now these
are called xenoestrogens and will
increase your estrogen in your body or
act like estrogen and it can cause
impotence and other health problems so
stay away from it all right now this one
a lot of you do it without even
realizing it
eating and drinking out of BPA
containers what is BPA well it stands
for buys female a this is in plastics
and it's dangerous because it is also a
xeno estrogen so you know that plastic
bottle that you keep in your cart don't
drink it is like poison especially when
it gets hot when it gets heated we will
get into the water and get into your
system and then suddenly you start to
experience hormonal problems and you
don't know why now if you want more tips
and style fitness grooming or life and
check out one of these videos
and I'll see you there cheers guys